is coming rounded winning points oh he
didn't spot that one Wesley is going to
pick up the B Pawn V3
you have to push B3 okay C2 and B3 yep
same idea but now it's uh I think it's
lost objectively yeah if the black
g-pawn was maybe back on its starting
Square you could have to build a
fortress but
okay he's trying to ask for The Rook
trade here if Rooks come off the board
white will win with his remaining Pawn
now the king is coming again two seconds
with the repetition
okay can the white king advance
wrestling wins even the eve wow couldn't
take the pawn because King G6 Checkmate
oh wow he car made a move with one
second left the pieces of flying all
over the board but white is totally
winning and Hikaru no handshake he
resigns or does he lose on time I think
he lost on time Wesley takes the win
that went down to the wire